now many of the individuals and
organizations we will describe today
were entrusted with keeping soccer open
and accessible to all they held
important responsibilities at every
level from building soccer fields for
children in developing countries to
organizing the World Cup they were
expected to uphold the rules that keep
soccer honest and to protect the
integrity of the game instead they
corrupted the business of worldwide
soccer to serve their interests and to
enrich themselves this Department of
Justice is determined to end these
practices to root out corruption and to
bring wrongdoers to justice now the 14
defendants charged in the indictment we
are unsealing today include high-ranking
officials of fifa the international
organization responsible for regulating
and promoting soccer leaders of regional
and other governing bodies under the
FIFA umbrella and sports marketing
executives who according to the
indictment paid millions of dollars in
bribes and kickbacks to obtain lucrative
media and marketing rights to
international soccer tournaments the 47
count indictment against these
individuals includes charges of
racketeering wire fraud and money
laundering conspiracies spanning two
decades